ما قالت صحيفه جورنال عن مسؤولينا ان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سلفن
اجرى اتصالات سريه مع كبار المساعدين
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن في محاوله
للحد من مخاطر نشوب صراع اوسع حول
اوكرانيا ولتحديد موسكو من مغبه لجوء بوتن
السلاح النووي او البيولوجي ونقلت الصحيفه
ان دعا الاوكرانيين مؤخرا ده للانفتاح على
حديث بشان حل النزاع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي دوافع واهدافه
الاتصالات السريه التي اجراها مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي مع كبار مساعديه
رئيس الروسي بوتن ولماذا ترفض موسكو
تاكيدها او نفيها هل تتركز الاتصالات
السريه على الحد من مخاطر اتساع التصعيد
فقط ام تشمل جوانب اخرى لم تاتي تسريبات
على ذكرها وكيف نفهم غياب الطرف الاوروبيه
عنها هل يمكن لهذه الاتصالات السريه ان
تفضي الى مفاوضات علنيه تضع حدا للحرب في
اوكرانيا وتداعيتها الدوليه والاقليميه
[موسيقى]
بينما تواصل رحل الحرب دورانها على يوميه
القتال بين الجيش الروسي والاوكراني
تفتحوا الولايات المتحده قناه اتصالات من
طرف خفي مع موسكو جميله على مستويات
متقابله مسؤولين كبارا من مساعدي الرئيس
الاسود
التي جرت في الاشهر الاخيره بين مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جاكسون ونظيره
نيكولا تيري مجلس الامن الروسي ويري
اوشكوف مساعد الرئيس الروسي تهدفه للحد من
مخاطر التصعيد ولابقاء القنوات مفتوحه
وليست لمناقشه تسويه للحرب
يقدر اثناء اعلن الكريمنين ان روسيا
ماتزال منفتحه على المحادثات مع اوكرانيا
وبشان ما نشرته صحيفه جورنال عن اجراء
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكسون
اتصالات سريه مع الجانب الروسي اعتبر
لكريملين ان وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه
الامريكيه ترد الكثير من ما وصفها
بالمعلومات الكاذبه
[موسيقى]
هناك شو الموضوع مع ضيفينا من موسكو
الدكتور ستانلسلام الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن الدكتور دونالد جنسن
الدبلوماسي الامريكي السابق في موسكو
مرحبا بكم
ابدا معك
واهداف هذه الاتصالات الامريكيه السريه
اعتقد انه يتعين علينا ان نتنبها
التقارير التي نشرت والامور التي لم تنشر
الامور المبهمه الامور التي لا نعرفها
ابدا اعتقد ان السيد سلفن والاداره
الامريكيه اييه تود ان
تحتوي الحرب وتاكد للرؤوس ان الامر يقضي
الى الدعم الديمقراطيه في اوكرانيا وليس
الى تغيير النظام لا نتحدث عن محادثات
سريه بل نتحدث عن قناه تواصل بين الجانبين
في هذه الازمه الخطره للغايه اتوقع ان
البيت الابيض يود ان يقول لبتون ولا
للكرملين اولا نحن ندعم اوكرانيا ثانيا
نحن ليس لدينا اهتمام بتغيير النظام في
روسيا والثالث ثانوي
حديث حديث بوتن حول استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه هو خطر وسوف يكون هناك تدعايات
الى ما حصل ذلك وبالتالي هذا يختلف عن
المفاوضات لا يمكننا ان نتحدث عن مفاوضات
بل هناك محاوله لرسم الخط الاحمر لكي تتضح
الصوره بالنسبه الى الروس ما هو مقبول ما
هو غير مقبول في سلوكيات روسيا وبالتالي
هذه ليست مفاوضات لهذا نحن نصر على
تسميتها باتصالات سريه ذكرت ما ما قد يكون
غير معلوم همم ما الذي همم يمكن ان يكون
قد بحث فعلا في هذه الاتصالات السوريه
السريه ولم يتم تسريبه ضغط جونسون ابقى
معك
نعم بالفعل هذه المسائل التي ذكرتها اعتقد
انها
تطرق عليها الطرفين انتقاد السلوك الروسي
2 الدعم لاوكرانيا ثلاثه وضع هذا الخط
الاحمر بالنسبه الى الامور التي لا نود ان
نقوم بها للحاق الضرر بروسيا بالاضافه الى
المساله النوويه ان روسيا تصرفت بطريقه
غير عقلانيه بتطرق الى هذه النقطه والتوتن
قال انه لا يخدع العالم بل هو يتكلم بجده
وبالتالي تود الولايات المتحده ان توضح
لروسيا اذا ما استخدم السلاح النووي حتى
التكيه سوف يكون هناك
بنسبه الى روسيا اعتقد ان هذه هي الاهداف
الثلاثه بنسبه الى البيت الابيض
تاكيد او نفي هذه التقارير عن الاتصالات
السريه بين موسكو واشنطن
على الارجح نحن في مرحله اوليه لمفاوضات
مستقبليه او تبادل افكار يمكن ان يؤدي
لاحقا الى مفاوضات وبالتالي الان ليس
الاوان لتاكيد ذلك لا من الجانب الروسي
ولا من الجانب الامريكي اعتقده ان هناك
بعض الاسباب التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى
مفاوضات في نهايه المطاف لان
المواجهات تدخل في مرحله قد تكون خطره
بنسبه الى روسيا والى الولايات المتحده
والى العالم الغربي عندما نتحدث عن المجال
النووي ما من احد يمكنه ان يشعر بالامان
لا في واشنطن ولا في موسكو نحن نعرفه هذه
الاستراتيجيه وهي استراتيجيه مدمره باضافه
الى ذلك هناك مساء الاقتصاديه الاقتصاد
الروسي يعاني من تداعيات العقبات ولكن
الاقتصاد الروسي لا يزال
استمرا ولكن المشاكل همم تزداد وفي اوروبا
هناك ازمه طاقه
وهناك همم تحول التدريجيا الى ازمه
اقتصاديه والسياسيه واجتماعيه يتعب الناس
في اوروبا اذا هذه الازمه والضروره بتقديم
الدعم لاوكرانيا على المستويات المختلفه
ووجدنا ايضا ان هناك اضطرابات اجتماعيه في
ايطاليا وفي دول اوروبيه اخرى وشاهدنا
المظاهرات حيث يرفع الناس الصوت همم ضد
التدخل المباشر للدول الاوروبيه ودول حلف
شمال الاطلسي بهذه الحرب
سببا اخر يدعون الى ربما التفكير بامكانيه
مفاوضات هو
الامكانيه المحدوده بنسبه الى اوكرانيا
بالنسبه
الى اوكرانيا على المستوى العسكري هذا
يشكل مشكله حتى ولا وصيطره على جزء من
خرسون في
الجانب من ضفه النهر ولكن هذا لا يمكن ان
يؤدي الى خروج القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل
من تلك الاراضي وبالتالي نتحدث عن مواجهه
طويله الامد والاطراف غير جاهزه لذلك
ولذلك هذه المرحله الاولى لربما يمكن ان
تتطور همم الى معاهده او اتفاقيه تشبه في
العام 2014 او 2015
قال ان بلاده من فتحه على تحقيق اهدافها
من خلال المفاوضات لكنها لا ترى امكانيه
لذلك بالنظر الى اقرار اكياس قانونا
رد الامتناع عن اي مفاوضات مع الجانب
الروسي بيسكوف علق ايضا على ما يروش بشان
اتصالات سريه امريكيه روسيه فقال يجب هنا
الاتصال بالبيت الابيض للتاكد من هذا
الخبر طيب دكتور مطرحوفيتش ابقى معك طالما
انه تقول بان هذه الاتصالات السريه ممكن
ان تفضي الى محادثات لماذا الكريم لاند
همم يمتنع من الاشاره حتى اليها ويقول
عليكم متابعه الاعلام الغربي باقتضاب لو
سمحت
رشا
تعتبر ان الجهه الفاعل الاساسيه هنا هي
البيت الابيض في واشنطن وليس الرئيس ذا
لانسكي او الاداره الاوكرانيه بالنسبه الى
روسيا نازلنسكي يستمع الى او ياخذ الاوامر
من البيت الابيض بنسبه الى المساله
الاستراتيجيه تلك ولذلك يجب التوصل الى
النوع من الاتفاق مع البيت الابيض وليس مع
الرئيس ظلال
ولماذا لا يدعم وجهه نظر هذه بان
المفاوضات يمكن ان تحصل في المستقبل نحن
نتحدث عن مرحله اوليه ولم نصل الى مرحله
مفاوضات وفي واشنطن همم لا يتفق الجميع
همم بالنسبه الى هذه النقطه ان يكون هناك
مفاوضات قبل هزيمه روسيا بنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده لربما في المستقبل قد
يحصل ذلك الرئيس الاوكراني
قال انه لا يرى رغبه من جانب روسيا في
التفاوض لانهاء نزاع بين البلدين واضاف في
كلمه الى شعبه عبر الفيديو قال نحن
مستعدون الان للسلام لكن روسيا تضلل
الجميع عندما تتحدث عن المفاوضات دكتور
جونسون الدكتور السنه سلاف اشار الى مسماه
تعب الشعب في اوروبا في اشاره الى الى
الاقتصاد طبعا بحسب الصحيفه همم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحث اوكرانيا على همم
ابراز ليونه للتفاوض مع الجانب الروسي
التوقيت اليس مستغرب لان ايضا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تقول الان بان اوكرانيا
تحقق انتصارات لا سيما في الجنوب وفي
الشرق بفضل الدعم الامريكي والدعم الغربي
للقوات الاوكرانيه كيف نفهم التوقيت هنا
اكشن اكشن
ممتاز بالفعل وكما تفضل الزميل من روسيا
هذا هو جوهر القضيه الطرفان لم يقترباه من
مفاوضات
والنظره باتجاه الحل تختلف بين طرفا واخر
ويجب تخفيض مستوى التوقعات على مستوى
الكرملين وايضا يجب استمرار الانتصارات
العسكريه الميدانيه بنسبه الى اوكرانيا
ولكن بعد التدخل الاوروبي اساسي من
الاهميه بما كان بالنسبه الى الاوروبيين
والبعض منهم قد يشكك باهميه دعم اوكرانيا
من الاهميه بالنسبه اليهم ان ينظر الى
زيلانسكي على انه الشخص يمكن ان يصل الى
اتفاق في حال ساعد ذلك اوكرانيا بالحديث
عن عدم التفاوض مع بوتن والاسود والابيض
بعض الحلفاء في اوروبا لربما يتساءل هل
هناك اتفاق على الطاوله ولكن ما من اتفاق
يطرح الان وه ااا تصريحات من الكريم
وتصريحات من واشنطن بانا اوكرانيا هي من
تقرر اذا ما تدخل في مباحثات ام لا نحن
نحاول ان نطمئن الحلفاء بان كاف سوف
تستفيد من اي فرصه لسلاما عادل ومستدام
وهذا يحفظ سياده واستقلال اوكرانيا
وبالتالي يجب ان نقرا بحذر الرساله هذه
الرساله لا تتوقف عند حدود روسيا
واوكرانيا والولايات المتحده بل ايضا
اوروبا انا شخصيا لا اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي التي تقرر بنسبه الى
اوكرانيا الولايات المتحده تدعم اوكرانيا
من خلال الاسلحه وتدعم من خلال المواقف
همم سياده اوكرانيا هذا هو الموقف
الامريكي ولكن في النهايه ما من همم حاجه
الى الشك بذلك الولايات المتحده تدعم
اوكرانيا واوكرانيا تقرر متى تذهب الى
طاوله مفاوضات اذا ما روسيا رات ان
اوكرانيا تتلقى الاوامر من الولايات
المتحده هي تقرا بطريقه خاطئه لاننا لا
نتحدث عن روسيا والولايات المتحده بل عن
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا هي فاعله اساسيه وهي
ضحيه اساسيه هذا هو الوضع بالنسبه اليه
دكتور هل ترون في دعوه واشنطن لاوكرانيا
لتبدي مرونه اكثر في التفاوض مع موسكو
ضغوط على اكياس في هذه المرحله
اغنيه
من الضغوط على كيفك الى
مستوى قد يؤدي الى
التقديم التنازلات لربما بالنسبه الى
الاراضي على المستوى الرسمي الخطاب هو
متشدد روسي يتعين عليها ان تخرج من كل
الاراضي التي تعتبرها اوكرانيا اراد تابعه
لها بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم ولكن من
الصعوبه لنا ان نتخيل كيف لبوتين ان يخرج
من القرم من دون تصعيد النوويه والمسؤولون
الاوكرانيون يطالبون بتعويضات وبم مدفوعات
كبيره
ومجددا يصعب لنا ان نتخيل ان بوتا او اي
شخص اخر يمكنه ان يلبي هذه الطلبات ايضا
هناك طلب
همم بتفكيك روسيا
الى الدول مختلفه انا لا اتوقع موفقه على
ذلك ولكن بنسبه الى التنازلات يمكن ان
تكون همم مقبوله باعاده الرسم الحدود
لربما يكون هناك تنازلات جزئيه من الجانب
الروسي كذلك وقد يؤدي ذلك على الاقل الى
وقفا مؤقت لاطلاق النار اعتقدوا ان
المشكله بنسبه الى اوكرانيا هي ان
اوكرانيا لا يمكنها ان تتقدم ميدانيا في
المستقبل لربما يمكنه ان تسيطر على اجزاء
من مدينه خرسان ولكن هذا هذه النهايه
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى تعزيزات اضافيه والى
اسلحه اضافيه من دول لست متاكدا مما اذا
كانت على استعدادا لتقديم الدعم لعقود او
سنوات وانا لست متاكدا من ان اوكرانيا
تخضع بهذا الدعم بالنسبه الى روسيا روسيا
غيروا اقتصادها لكي يصبح عسكريا نعم حصلت
تعبئه وهناك حاجه لانتظار لاشهر لاتمام
هذه التعبئه ولكن بعد انتهاء التعبئه سوف
يصبح الجيش الروسي اكبر وبالتالي هذا مازق
عسكري او حائط يمكن ان يؤدي الى مفاوضات
هل هذه هي النقطه همم دكتور جونسون
التعزيزات الاضافيه لانه ايضا بحسب
التسريبات بان واشنطن تريد موقفا اكثر
ليون لان همم يعني لا تريد ان ترسل اشارات
خاطئه الى دول ما تزال تدعم اوكرانيا يعني
هل هنا النقطه بان يعني بمعنى اخر همم
الدول الاوروبيه تعبت من دعم اوكرانيا في
هذه الحرب التالي تريد ان تجد مخرجا وقد
يكون التفاوض بعيدا عن السريه
على فكره اعتقد انه من الاهميه للغايه
اللا نخفف من اهميه ما يحصل في اوروبا
بنسبه الى التعب الذي اشارتهم اليه
اعتقدوا ان الحلفاء في اوروبا يتوحدون في
دعم اوكرانيا وخصوصا المانيا ولكن هناك
بعض المشاكل ويجب التطرق اليها
والطريقه الوحيده هي اذا ما قالنسكي
للحلفاء في اوروبا ان اوكرانيا مستعده
لوصولي الى سلاما عادل
ونحن لا نزل بعدين عن هذا المستوى وكما
ذكر الزميل قد يكون سيناريو في المستقبل
ولكن لم نصل الى هذه المرحله بعد هناك
سلسله من الاجتماعات على مستوى المانيا
وعلى مستوى خلف شمال الاطلسي مستوى الدعم
من اوروبا وليس فقط من الولايات المتحده
هو كبير له طرحتم السؤال
سته اشهر او قبل سته اشهر هل كانت اوروبا
سوف تتوحد في دعمها لكيف لربما معظم الناس
كانوا لقيون كلا ولكن ها نحن نشهد هذا
الدعم واشنطن ترحب بذلك دكتور ستانلس
الشروط الاوكرانيه واضحه لا تفاوض مع
الرئيس بوتن اكياف تنتظر طبعا ان ياتي
رئيس جديد همم واما ان تنسحب القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه طب نريد ان
نفهم ما هي الشروط الروسيه
لتحول هذه الاتصالات السريه الى مفاوضات
وانت اشرت في البدايه لانه من الممكن ان
تتحول الى الى محادثات اقله لهدنا اذا لم
تكن لوقفت اطلاق النار ما هي الشروط
الروسيه لانطلاق هكذا مباحثات او محادثات
اعتقد ان الشروط الروسيه للوصول الى هتلر
يمكن ان تكون اولا سيطره
بشكل امن على الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا باستثناء خرسون وهي في الجانب
الايمن للنهر ومن الصعوبه في مكان ان
تدافع عنها القوات الروسيه وكل شيء اخر
على الارجح يبقى تحت السيطره الروسيه يمكن
ان توقف روسيا الضربات التي تستهدف البنا
التحتيه الاساسيه الحيويه من مثلي همم
هزيمه من قبل اوكرانيه وهي ترفضه تماما
الكونغ فو
البديل عما قلته هو
انتصار عسكري لاي من الطرفين ولكن لا
يمكنني ان ارى كيف لروسيا ان تحقق هذا
النصر بشكل كامل ولا كيف يمكن اوكرانيا ان
تهزم روسيا بشكل كامل بما في ذلك الحصول
على او استعاده السيطره على شبه جزيره
القرم حتى مع كل الدعم الامريكي والاوروبي
سوف تكون حربا مفتوحه لعقود والسؤال هل
سوف تمد الولايات المتحده اوروبا اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه لعقود اذن البديل هو نزاع مفتوح
ولا اعتقد ان الغرب يمكنه ان يتحمل ذلك
والامر الصيام بالنسبه الى روسيا ان
النزاع طويل الامد لن يقبله الراي العام
الروسي
الدكتور جونسون دكتور جونسون باربعين
ثانيه لو سمحت
ما الذي قد يحول هذه الاتصالات السريه الى
مباحثات مباشره في ظل هذه المواقف
اوكرانيا تقول الانسحاب بينما سمعت ضيفنا
يقول السيطره على هذه المناطق ومن ثم ممكن
الحوار باقتضاب لو سمحت
ضرر في التحضر
لسيناريوهات مختلفه حول الشكل المفاوضات
المحتمله ولكن انا والاداره الامريكيه
والاداره في كيف لا ينظرون الى هذا
الاحتمال على انه قائم الان اعتقد انه يجب
ان نتجهز الى امكانيه حصول ذلك ولكننا لم
نقترب من هذه المرحله
والمشكله من المشكلات انه بعد سبع اشهر من
قتل الروس
والقذف البنا التحتيه عدد كبير من الناس
في كل انحاء العالم
انتهى وقت تماما شكرا لك في واشنطن
الدكتور دونالد جونسون وفي موسكو الدكتور
الثاني سلاف متوفيتش
شكرا المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]